I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, Angela. Hi there. We need to go on a search. We sure do. For Michael Scott, who is just wandering around Scranton today. Yeah, he's going on a walkabout. It is season 7, episode 15. It's called The Search. It was written by Brent Forrester and directed by a new director, Michael Spiller. So nice. So nice. Michael is the loveliest. Well, you
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作专属的《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。你好，安吉拉。你好呀。我们需要去寻找一个人。我们当然得去。寻找迈克尔·斯科特，他今天正漫无目的地在斯克兰顿闲逛。对，他要去进行漫游。这是第七季第十五集。剧名叫《搜寻》。由布伦特·福斯特编剧，由新导演迈克尔·斯皮勒执导。太棒了。太棒了。迈克尔人最好了。嗯，你知道
know, he was a cinematographer and a director, which made him perfect for our show. Here's something that I didn't know, though. He was the cinematographer for the first four seasons of Sex and the City. Oh. Why didn't I know that? So I could pepper him with questions. I would have had so many questions. Right? This is before we Googled. I know. It wasn't before Google. Google was there, but it's before you and I Googled. We were not ladies who Google yet. Mm-mm. Michael also won an Emmy for Outstanding Direction for a Comedy Series for Modern Family. So we were in very good hands. How about a summary? Yep. When Jim leaves Michael at a gas station without his phone or wallet, Michael goes on a walkabout
的，他以前是摄影指导兼导演，这让他非常适合我们的节目。不过，有一点我之前并不知道。他曾是前四季《欲望都市》的摄影指导。哦。我怎么不知道这事？这样我就能抛出一连串问题问他了。我肯定会有超多问题。对吧？这是在我们习惯用谷歌搜索之前。我知道。倒也不是没有谷歌。谷歌当时就有了，但那是你和我还没开始用谷歌搜索之前。我们当时还不是爱用谷歌搜索的女士。嗯-嗯。迈克尔还凭借《摩登家庭》获得过艾美奖喜剧类剧集最佳导演奖。所以我们这次有极好的保障。来个剧情梗概吧？好的。当吉姆把迈克尔一个人留在加油站，既没带手机也没带钱包时，迈克尔便开始了他在
around Scranton. Meanwhile, Dwight, Aaron, and Holly set out to find him. Back at the office, Pam's artwork on the office fridge inspires some silly captions from her coworkers, resulting in a caption contest at Gabe's expense. Are you ready for FastFact number one? I am. Well, this one is coming at you straight from Brent Forrester. Brent is awesome and his enthusiasm about writing these episodes is always such a delight. I love hearing from him. I know. He loves writing in general. He loves storytelling. Well, he sent in an audio clip about how this episode is the perfect rom-com. I got so lucky when I was assigned to write this episode because it's the climax of the Michael Holly romantic
斯克兰顿周边的漫游。与此同时，德怀特、亚伦和霍莉出发去寻找他。回到办公室里，帕姆在办公室冰箱上的画作激发了同事们的一些搞笑配音灵感，由此引发了一场以盖布为调侃对象的配音大赛。你们准备好听冷知识第一条了吗？准备好了。嗯，这一条直接来自布伦特·福斯特。布伦特太棒了，他对撰写这些剧集的激情总是让人感到非常高兴。我喜欢听他分享。我知道。他非常热爱写作本身。他热爱讲故事。嗯，他发来了一段音频剪辑，讲述了这一集是如何成为一部完美的浪漫喜剧的。我被指派来写这一集时真是太幸运了，因为这是迈克尔和霍莉之间贯穿整部剧多年的浪漫
subplot that's been running through the show for years. And the episode itself is structured like a classic rom-com. Holly denies that they're made for each other, but each beat of the story seems to prove that they are made for each other. And then they meet in this classic romantic comedy trope, the meeting on the rooftop of the Empire State Building from an affair to remember and sleepless in Seattle. But because it's the office, it's not a glamorous art deco setting. It's this seedy rooftop in Scranton. All of that story material was just handed to me. Greg and the writing staff came up with it and I was assigned to write it. And I get to say, written by Brent Forrester. It's funny when I saw that rooftop
支线剧情的高潮。而且这一集本身的结构就像是一部经典的浪漫喜剧。霍莉否认他们天生是一对，但故事的每一个节拍似乎都在证明他们确实天生一对。然后他们在经典的浪漫喜剧桥段中相遇——就像《金玉盟》和《西雅图夜未眠》里帝国大厦屋顶的相遇。但因为这是《办公室》，所以它不是那种光鲜亮丽的装饰艺术风格背景，而是斯克兰顿一个破旧的屋顶。所有这些故事素材都是直接送到我手里的。格雷格和编剧团队想出了这个点子，然后我被指派来写剧本。而且我可以自豪地说，编剧：布伦特·福斯特。有趣的是，当我看到这一集末尾那个在屋顶
kissing scene at the end of this episode, I had the thought, why did they pick such an ugly roof? And it was clearly intentional. They're like, this is the office version of the rom-com right Empire State Building. I recently rewatched sleepless in Seattle. It's so charming. It totally holds up. I don't remember that one. I think I'm mixing it up in my mind. Tom Yanks and Meg Ryan. I thought that was you got mail. Well, they did that later. They did that later. But sleepless in Seattle is so sweet. Oh my gosh, you have to watch it. Maybe we should watch it together. Maybe we should watch it and break it down. Okay. Put a pin in that. Brent also shared with us the caption contest storyline in this episode.
接吻的场景时，我心里想，他们为什么挑了一个这么丑的屋顶？而且这显然是刻意为之的。他们就像是在说，这就是浪漫喜剧中帝国大厦的办公室版本。我最近重温了《西雅图夜未眠》。太有魅力了。完全经得起时间的考验。我不记得那部了。我想我把它在脑子里记混了。汤姆·扬克斯和梅格·瑞恩。我以为那是《电子情书》。哦，那是他们后来的作品。那是他们后来的作品。但《西雅图夜未眠》太温馨了。哦天哪，你一定要看看。也许我们应该一起看。也许我们应该把它看一遍并好好剖析一下。好的。先把这个话题放一放。布伦特还跟我们分享了这一集里的配音大赛支线剧情。
He said that idea came because Justin Spitzer, one of our other writers, had submitted a caption to the New Yorker Cartoon Contest, and they kept waiting to see if his caption was going to get picked, but he didn't win. And so they got to talking about it, joking about it, and they thought that seems like something Oscar would do. Oscar would submit a caption for a contest, but that eventually grew into this B story. And Brent said he thought it was perfect because every character was going to get at least one memorable moment because we were going to get to hear their caption or hear their thoughts on the contest. And it really worked. He said it was a great group B story storyline. Fast fact number two, you might notice Jim is not around much in
他说这个灵感是因为贾斯汀·斯皮策，我们的另一位编剧，曾向《纽约客》漫画大赛提交过一个配音，他们一直等着看他的配音会不会被选中，但他没能获奖。于是他们开始讨论这事，开玩笑说，他们觉得这看起来像是奥斯卡会做的事。奥斯卡会为某个比赛提交一个配音，而这个想法最终发展成了这条B线剧情。布伦特说他觉得这太完美了，因为每个角色都能获得至少一个令人难忘的高光时刻，因为我们能听到他们的配音或者他们对这场比赛的想法。这效果确实很好。他说这是一条非常棒的群戏B线剧情。冷知识第二条，你可能会注意到吉姆在这一集里
this episode. I noticed he was still off in Alaska shooting Big Miracle. You know, it was directed by Ken Quapas. We mentioned that last week. I got curious about the film because I'm like, John's been gone now for like three episodes. Yeah, what's he doing? What's he up there doing? I remembered that the movie was based on a true story of three California whales that got trapped in the ice in Alaska, and then everybody banded together to save the whales. But I found an audio clip. So he starred in this movie with Ted Danson, Drew Barrymore, Kristen Bell, and Ken Quapas starts out the audio clip. Here it is. In the northernmost town in our hemisphere, off the coast of Alaska, three California gray whales were discovered trapped in the ice. You
露面不多。我注意到他当时还在阿拉斯加拍摄《奇迹大救援》。你知道的，那是由肯·库帕斯执导的。我们上周提到了。我对这部电影很好奇，因为我想，约翰已经离开大概有三集了吧。对啊，他在那儿干什么呢？他去那儿做什么呢？我记得这部电影是根据真实故事改编的，讲述了三条加州灰鲸被困在阿拉斯加的冰层中，然后大家齐心协力去拯救鲸鱼的故事。但我找到了一段音频剪辑。所以他与泰德·丹森、德鲁·巴里摩尔、克里斯汀·贝尔一同主演了这部电影，音频剪辑由肯·库帕斯开头。就是这个。在我们的半球最北端的小镇，阿拉斯加海岸附近，人们发现三条加州灰鲸被困在冰里。你
got to see this. Three gray whales are now trapped in walls of ice six inches thick. You have whales in trouble and you didn't call me. I didn't call you because there's nothing you can do. There's always something you can do. NBC put it on national news that evening. Within 24 hours, every news service sent reporters to Alaska. There were over 150 journalists that flew to Barrow to report this story. This media circus sort of grew on the ice. It captured the imagination of the world. And so everybody comes to the table to start an effort and a movement to save these whales. The Inupia people, oil companies, United States military. You ready to do this? Russia, Greenpeace activists. Why won't you give us a chance to get them out? Everyone is doing it for
得来看看这个。三条灰鲸现在被困在六英寸厚的冰墙里。你们有鲸鱼遇到麻烦了，居然不叫我。我没叫你是因为你什么也做不了。总有些事情是你能做的。那天傍晚，全国广播公司（NBC）将其播出了全国新闻。在24小时内，各大新闻机构都派记者前往阿拉斯加。有150多名记者飞往巴罗来报道这个故事。这场媒体狂欢在冰面上蔓延开来。它抓住了全世界的想象力。于是每个人都走到一起，开始发起一项拯救这些鲸鱼的努力和运动。因纽皮雅特人、石油公司、美国军方。准备好了吗？俄罗斯、绿色和平组织活动人士。为什么不给我们一个机会把它们弄出来呢？每个人都在为了
their own reasons. But that's not always bad. We are all more similar than we're dissimilar. The right cause at the right time will always win out. There's so much like us. We get scared and we're vulnerable and we need help sometimes too. It is a really beautiful story. Okay. Thank you for listening to that whole clip of them promoting this movie because after I found it, I was crying. I was like, yes, the world needs this. This is so wonderful. Everyone came together. This movie got great reviews. It has a great tomato rating. It is a family film. I'm going to watch this with my family. I'll report back. Okay. Are you ready for Fastpack number three? I am. This one is a fan question from Jessica N in Rochester, New York.
各自的理由这样做。但这并不总是坏事。我们彼此之间的相似点远多于不同点。在正确的时间选择正确的正义事业终将胜利。它们太像我们了。我们会感到害怕，我们会感到脆弱，有时我们也需要帮助。这真的是一个非常美丽的故事。好了。谢谢你们听完整段他们宣传这部电影的音频，因为我找到它后，我都哭了。我当时就想，是的，世界需要这个。这太美妙了。大家齐心协力。这部电影获得了极好的评价。它在烂番茄上有着很高的评分。这是一部合家欢电影。我要和家人一起看。回头我再向大家汇报。好的。你们准备好听冷知识第三条了吗？准备好了。这一条来自纽约州罗切斯特市的杰西卡·N的粉丝提问。
Jessica would like to know, where did you film the Michael Lost in Wandering Scenes for this episode? Was it all in one area? Were there multiple locations? They did a really good job of stitching it all together so it looked like the same place in the same time of day. Well, Jessica, we checked in with Randy Cordray on this and guess what? This episode was a quote logistical nightmare. I bet they went to so many locations and they would have to move everybody every time. Yeah. There were 10 different locations for this episode. That's including actual restaurants and shops, but also just cars and shots on the street of Michael Wandering. We filmed this not only over multiple days, but over multiple weeks.
杰西卡想知道，迈克尔迷路和闲逛的那些场景是在哪里拍摄的？是都在同一个地方吗？还是有多个取景地？他们把这些场景拼接得非常棒，看起来就像是同一地点、一天的同一时间。嗯，杰西卡，我们向兰迪·科德雷核实了这个情况，你猜怎么着？这一集简直堪称“后勤噩梦”。我敢打赌他们去了好多地方，而且每次都得把所有人都转移。对啊。这一集共有10个不同的取景地。这不仅包括真正的餐厅和商店，还包括汽车以及迈克尔闲逛的街头镜头。我们不仅花了几天时间拍摄，而是花了数周时间。
In order to clear John for his movie, we actually shot the scenes of him and Steve driving and then the scenes of them at the gas station the previous week when we were shooting the seminar. So we had to match that. Then a week later over multiple days, nothing was within walking distance from one another. That's a real gamble. Think about it. What if the day they shot with Steve and John the week before was super sunny? Then what if we got some weird weather surge and it was all overcast and stuff? Yeah, I know. Or if it had rained, which never happens, but could happen. Could happen. In fact, the minute you schedule something like this in film or television, this happens. Randy must have been so stressed out.
为了让约翰能腾出时间去拍他的电影，我们实际上在前一周拍摄研讨会时，就把他和史蒂夫开车以及他们在加油站的场景给拍了。所以我们必须把后面的画面跟那个对接上。然后一周后，经过了好几天的拍摄，没有哪个地方是步行就能互相到达的。这真是一场豪赌。想想看，万一他们前一周和史蒂夫、约翰拍戏的那天阳光灿烂呢？那要是碰上什么奇怪的天气突变，全都是阴天什么的怎么办？对啊，我懂。或者要是下雨了呢——虽然这事从没发生过，但也可能会发生。是有可能的。事实上，你在电影或电视里只要安排这种日程，这事就会发生。兰迪当时肯定压力山大。
He had a big thank you. He said, quote, this episode truly showed the expertise of our beloved location manager, Kyle Alexander and his team. Randy said, I have raved about Kyle in the past, but this particular episode was a massive challenge, one that he delivered with perfection. He said, Kyle not only had to find suitable spaces to satisfy the needs of each scene creatively, but he also had to consider the entire shooting company in terms of parking, base camps, trailers, generators, proximity. Like we moved a couple times, but not too many times. He said he had a very small team. It was just himself, Christian Krieger and Anna Coates, just three people. Wow. Randy went on to say that they were one of his favorite departments to work
他特别感谢了一个人。他说，引述一下：“这一集真正展现出了我们深爱的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大和他的团队的专业水准。”兰迪说，我过去对凯尔赞不绝口，但这一集绝对是个巨大的挑战，他以完美的方式完成了任务。他说，凯尔不仅要找到合适的场地来满足每个场景的创意需求，还得从停车、大本营、拖车、发电机、距离等方方面面考虑整个摄制组的情况。就像我们搬迁了好几次，但次数也不算太多。他说他只有一个非常小的团队。只有他自己、克里斯汀·krieger和安娜·科茨，总共就三个人。哇。兰迪接着说，他们是他最喜欢合作的部门之一。
with. They were always drama free, which is good. He says, as I always say about putting together a crew for a comedy, quote, the last thing I want to see is drama. I will share more about each of the individual locations as we break them down, but we were everywhere from North Hollywood Studio City all the way to downtown LA. I can't wait. I love your location breakdowns, lady. Well, I got some fun little tidbits about them too. Okay. I love a tidbit. But before we go to break, Angela, I got this fan question in the fan mail inbox. I don't know where or when to ask you this. Oh my gosh. But it is a question for you. What? So I thought I'd throw it in. Okay. It's from Shannon S. in Grand Haven, Michigan. I watched a new girl episode about Jess's birthday.
他们总是没有狗血抓马，这很好。他说，正如我常说的，在为喜剧组建剧组时，引述一下：“我最不想看到的就是狗血抓马。”等我们逐一剖析时，我会分享更多关于每个独立取景地的细节，但我们的足迹遍布从北好莱坞影视城一直到洛杉矶市中心的各个地方。我等不及了。我喜欢你的外景剖析，女士。嗯，我也有关于这些地方的一些有趣小花絮。好的。我最喜欢花絮了。但在我们进入广告休息之前，安吉拉，我在粉丝邮件收件箱里收到了这个粉丝提问。我都不知道该在哪里或者什么时候问你这个。哦天哪。但这确实是一个问你的问题。什么？所以我打算把它抛出来。好的。这是密歇根州大黑文市的香农·S提问的。我看了一集关于杰茜生日的《杰茜驾到》。
In that episode, Angela guest starred. And as she was speaking to Zoe's character, she called her lady. Angela, was that scripted or just you? Just me. Yay. New girl was so much fun. I know I've talked about it before, but it really felt like our set in the way that we got everything as it was written. And sometimes we could play around a little bit and some improvs would make it in. But that was a fantastic and fun show to be a part of. And those guys are doing a podcast about that show now too, right? Yeah, they sure are. Hannah and Zoe and Lamorn, it's called Welcome to Our Show. Well, Shannon, you might want to check it out as a new girl fan. I'll have to go on it when they do my episode. You will. Call her lady again.
在那一集中，安吉拉客串出演了。当她和佐伊的角色说话时，她叫了对方“女士”。安吉拉，那是剧本写的，还是你即兴发挥的？我自己发挥的。耶。拍《杰茜驾到》太好玩了。我知道我以前说过，但它真的让我感觉就像我们的片场一样，我们完全按照剧本拍摄。有时候我们可以稍微自由发挥一下，有些即兴发挥的内容会被保留到正片里。但那是部非常棒、非常好玩的剧集，能参与其中真的很开心。而且那些家伙现在也在为那部剧做播客对吧？对，他们当然在做。汉娜、佐伊和拉莫恩，播客名叫《欢迎来到我们的节目》。好吧，香农，作为《杰茜驾到》的粉丝，你可能会想去听听。等他们讲到我那一集的时候，我得去上一次。你一定要去。到时候再叫她一声“女士”。
I have one little tidbit before we go to break. The original title for this episode was Lost. Oh, not the search, but Lost. I think I would have found that confusing. That makes me think of Lost the TV show. Oh, I would be. I don't know. I'm glad they changed it. Me too. I feel like the search is a little bit more positive sounding than Lost. Also, he's on a search. Yes. It's layered. Yes. A search for love. Really? Yeah. In the end. All right. Well, let's take a break. We'll be right back. Yeah. Kelly and Ryan are going to make a very important announcement. They got divorced over the weekend. And the whole bullpen is like, wait, what? When were
在我们进入广告休息之前，我还有一个小花絮。这一集的最初片名是《迷失》。哦，不是《搜寻》，而是《迷失》。我觉得这会让我觉得很困惑。这让我想起了电视剧《迷失》。哦，我会的。我不知道。我很高兴他们改了名字。我也是。我觉得《搜寻》听起来比《迷失》稍微更积极一点。而且，他是在搜寻。是的。很有层次感。是的。对爱的搜寻。真的吗？对。最后是的。好吧，那我们休息一下。马上回来。对。凯利和瑞安要宣布一个非常重要的消息。他们周末离婚了。然后整个办公室的人都一脸懵，等等，什么？你们什么时候
you married? Like, what are you talking about? I have some background catches for y'all. Yeah. If you go to three seconds, you will catch two people who are not ready for this scene to start. Who are they? They are not in character. They are. Number one, Rayne Wilson. He is putting his phone away quickly in his top left desk drawer. Okay. That's where he'd keep his phone busted. Number two, I am surfing the internet. Wow. Yeah. And at 41 seconds, Creed was playing Solitaire. Hmm. Angela, we got a fan question about this cold open from Kristen Pee in Indiana. Kristen wants to know, was there a different cold open originally planned for this episode? I noticed Jim and Michael are not in the cold open. Have they already left for their sales meeting?
结过婚的？什么情况？我有几个给你们大家准备的背景抓帮。耶。如果你看到第3秒，你会发现有两个演员还没准备好这个场景开始。是谁？他们根本没进入角色。他们是。第一位，雷恩·威尔逊。他正手忙脚乱地把手机塞进他左上角的办公桌抽屉里。好的。这就是他藏手机的地方，当场抓获。第二位，我在网上冲浪。哇。对的。在第41秒，克里德在玩纸牌游戏。嗯。安吉拉，我们收到了一条关于这个片头冷开场的粉丝提问，来自印第安纳州的克里斯汀·P。克里斯汀想知道，这一集原本是不是计划了一个不同的片头冷开场？我注意到吉姆和迈克尔没有出现在片头冷开场里。他们当时已经去开销售会议了吗？
Or maybe this cold open was originally meant to take place somewhere in the middle of the episode. That is a great question, Kristen. And really good background catches. I noticed that Michael and Jim weren't there either. I did go to the shooting draft because I was curious. And this scene was always the cold open, always in every draft that I read. But it was longer and it was immediately followed with Jim trying to get Michael out the door. Interesting. I want to read to you guys the extended part of the scene that was in the shooting draft because it really made me laugh, the Kelly and Ryan dialogue. So the line, Ryan, I changed my mind that Kelly says, would have been followed up with this. Ryan would have said, I know I'm ignoring it because you
或者也许这个片头冷开场原本是打算放在这一集中间的某个地方？这是个很好的问题，克里斯汀。而且你抓的背景细节真好。我也注意到迈克尔和吉姆不在那儿。我特意去看了拍摄初稿，因为我很好奇。而且这个场景一直都是片头冷开场，在我读过的每一个版本的初稿里都是如此。但它原本更长，紧接着就是吉姆试图把迈克尔弄出门。很有趣。我想向大家读一下拍摄初稿中那个被删减的场景部分，因为凯利和瑞安的对话真的把我逗笑了。所以凯利说的这句台词，“瑞安，我改变主意了”，后面原本应该接的是这些。瑞安会说，我知道，我根本不理会，因为你
change your mind every two seconds. And then Kelly would have said, well, I'm not going to have sex with someone who's not my husband. Then Ryan says, we should take baby steps, maybe start dating again. And Kelly said, I don't date divorced guys. There's always something wrong with them. This is very funny. And then it would have cut to Jim saying, Michael, come on. Interesting. All right. Michael is not leaving, by the way, because he's in the kitchen and he's asking Holly, when can they start dating? She broke up with AJ and he doesn't understand. Like, why can't they date? They're like magnets. They're meant to stick together. Holly says to Michael, look, I can't just date someone every time I move offices.
每两秒钟就改变一次主意。然后凯利会说，哼，我才不会和一个不是我丈夫的人发生关系。接着瑞安说，我们应该循序渐进，也许重新开始约会吧。凯利说，我不和离过婚的男人约会。他们身上总有些毛病。这段非常搞笑。然后画面本该切到吉姆说，迈克尔，快来吧。很有趣。好了。顺便说一句，迈克尔并没有离开，因为他在厨房里问霍莉，他们什么时候可以开始约会？她和AJ分手了，而他搞不懂。为什么他们不能约会？他们就像磁铁一样。他们天生就该黏在一起。霍莉对迈克尔说，听着，我不能每次换办公室就跟人约会。
I get that. I don't know. I'm with Michael. We just like get together already. So we know these two are meant to be. Holly, you know it. I know it. We all know it. Before Jim leaves, he has a cute little flirty flirt. There's a flirty Jim Pam moment. Yeah, we threw one in there. He's taken one of Pam's doodles, which by the way, that's a big doodle. Can we talk about that? Aren't doodles usually little things you do in the corner of a piece of paper? This was a huge doodle. It was a whole printer. Maybe he enlarged it. Maybe it was smaller and he used the enlarge button. Also, they say that you can tell things about people about what they doodle. There's like personality tests. So Pam's doodling a printer. I'm so bummed right
我懂。我不知道。我站迈克尔这边。我们快在一起吧。所以我们都知道这两个人天生是一对。霍莉，你知道。我知道。我们大家都知道。吉姆离开之前，他来了一次可爱的小调情。有一个吉姆和帕姆的调情高光时刻。对，我们在里面加了一个。他拿走了帕姆涂鸦中的一个，顺便说一句，那是个大涂鸦。我们能聊聊这个吗？难道涂鸦不通常是你在一张纸的角落里随手画的小东西吗？这可是个巨大的涂鸦。整整一台打印机。也许他把它放大了。也许它原本很小，他用了放大按钮。另外，他们说你可以通过一个人的涂鸦看出他们的性格。类似于性格测试。所以帕姆涂鸦画了一台打印机。我此刻感到非常沮丧，
now in this moment that we didn't Google that we didn't deep dive. I know what doodles mean about you. Yeah. I usually doodle a flower. What does that mean? I don't know, but I usually doodle a little cartoon of myself talking. Sam, Cassie, do you guys doodle? That's based on my old cartooning days. No, not really a doodler, Cassie. I doodled a lot in high school when I was listening to lectures, but I did just look up an article about what specific doodles mean. Oh, what do they mean? So this is 99designs.com. There is a people category. So drawing human figures indicates a successful person, someone with a healthy self-image who connects identity to a complete body. Wow. Yeah. That's great. What about people who draw plants or flowers? My second most popular doodle
我们当时居然没有去谷歌搜索，没有进行深入研究。我知道涂鸦对你意味着什么。对。我通常会涂鸦一朵花。那是什么意思？我不知道，但我通常会画一个自己正在说话的小卡通画。萨姆、卡西，你们会涂鸦吗？那是基于我以前画卡通画的日子。不，我不太画涂鸦，卡西。我在高中听讲座时画过很多涂鸦，但我刚刚确实查了一篇文章，讲的是特定涂鸦意味着什么。哦，它们是什么意思？所以这是99designs.com网站上的内容。里面有一个“人物”分类。所以画人物形象表明这是一个成功的人，一个有着健康的自我形象、将自我认同与完整身体联系起来的人。哇。对啊。太棒了。那画植物或花朵的人呢？我的第二大最受欢迎的涂鸦
is a tree. Okay. I drew a lot of trees in high school too, but I did find flowers. It is one of the most popular drawing motifs. I'm basic. But it does say specific types of flowers. Do you remember what types of flowers or what they look like? I do like daisies. Okay. So circular flowers with rounded petals. And sometimes I do them on a vine, you know? Okay. So circular flowers is one of the most positive flower doodles. Hey, you're a positive person. That sounds a lot like Angela. Yeah. Did you find out anything about trees, Cassie? Yeah. I'm trying to look that up. If you draw trees next to homes, it's a sense of security. Oh. And it also represents growth in life. We're very positive doodlers. That's what I found out. Oh, that's the title of our next book,
是一棵树。好的。我在高中时也画过很多树，但我确实查到了花朵。它是最受欢迎的绘画主题之一。我很基础。但它确实提到了特定类型的花。你还记得是什么类型的花或者它们长什么样吗？我确实喜欢雏菊。好的。也就是带有圆润花瓣的圆形花朵。有时候我把它们画在藤蔓上，你知道的？好的。圆形花朵是最积极的花朵涂鸦之一。嘿，你是个积极的人。这听起来很像安吉拉。对。卡西，你有没有查到关于树木的内容？对。我正在努力查那个。如果你在房子旁边画树，那就代表一种安全感。哦。它还代表着生活中的成长。我们是非常积极的涂鸦者。这就是我查到的结果。哦，那是我们下一本书的书名，
Positive Doodlers. Wait, I have a question. What does it say about people who draw appliances or like... Yeah, or electrical equipment. Equipment. I'm not seeing... I'm seeing vehicles if you draw like trucks or boats. That's like you want to escape. You want to go on vacation. Okay. I often doodle a palm tree on an island. Same. Same with the ocean and the sun. It's even in our book, The Office BFFs, because I doodled while I was in the background of seeing a palm tree on an island. I don't want to know the meaning of Oscar's doodles, which you also put in our book. I know, he always would draw me and Brian, but he would draw us as the accountants, like up to Mischief. Well, Cassie, let us know if you find out why Pam was compelled to doodle a giant
《积极的涂鸦者》。等等，我有个问题。画家用电器或者像……对，或者电子设备的人，上面是怎么说的？设备。我没看到……如果你画卡车或船之类的，我看到的是交通工具。那就像是你想逃离。你想去度假。好的。我经常在岛上涂鸦一棵棕榈树。我也是。海滩和太阳也是。甚至在我们的书《办公室闺蜜》里也有，因为我在背景里时就涂鸦了一棵岛上的棕榈树。我可不想知道奥斯卡涂鸦的意思，那也被你放进我们的书里了。我知道，他总是把我跟布赖恩画进去，但他会把我们画成会计师，一副要恶作剧的样子。好吧，卡西，如果你查到了为什么帕姆会情不自禁地在一张全尺寸纸上涂鸦一个巨大的打印机，请务必告诉我们。对，就像涂鸦的尺寸。嗯，吉姆对帕姆的涂鸦非常自豪，并把它贴在了冰箱上。
printer on a full-sized piece of paper. Yeah, like size of doodle. Yeah. Well, Jim is very proud of Pam's doodle, and he has put it on the fridge. Yeah. We are now in the car with Michael and Jim. I'm going to call this scene under the nose camera angle. Sorry, fellas, but that lipstick camera was real low. Yeah, we used an insert car for this. That meant that we were actually towing Jim's Subaru. The camera was all lipstick cameras, like you mentioned. We also had LAPD working some traffic control for us as we pulled that car down the street at four minutes, 13 seconds, you know, when Jim turns on the radio for some music. That was a track that was owned by Universal Music, so we were able to get by with only paying $1,500. Oh, I know. Remember last week,
对。我们现在和迈克尔、吉姆一起坐在车里。我要把这个场景称为“鼻尖下方的摄像机视角”。对不起啦，各位，但那个唇膏镜头放得可真低啊。对，我们为这拍用了一辆拖车。这意味着我们实际上是在拖着吉姆的斯巴鲁前行。摄像机全都是唇膏镜头，就像你提到的那样。当我们把那辆车沿着街道拉到4分13秒时，洛杉矶警察局还为我们做了一些交通管制，你知道的，吉姆打开收音机听音乐的时候。那是环球音乐拥有的音轨，所以我们只花了1500美元就搞定了。哦，我懂。记得上周，我们聊过音乐预算。大钱，大钱。
we talked about music budget. Big money, big money. Yeah. So there is a moment in this scene that I felt like was me on any road trip. In fact, I feel like I have said this out loud or a version of it, maybe not so angry to my husband. I really need you to hear it. It's when Michael says he has to pee. I need to pee. No, you don't. Yeah, I do. My word against yours. All right. Well, we'll be there in 10 minutes. What part of I need to pee? Do you not understand? I'm upset. My bladder is full. There is no telling what I might do right now, all over the inside of your precious little car. All right. Well, if I see a gas station, I'll pull over. Well, I hope I make it. I feel like I've said, well, I hope I make it. I feel like I have. Oh, you guys,
所以这个场景里有一个时刻，我觉得简直就是我在任何公路旅行中的真实写照。事实上，我觉得我有大声说出过这句话或者类似的版本，也许对老公没那么生气。我真的需要你们听听。就是迈克尔说他必须去洗手间的时候。我得去尿尿。不，你不需要。不，我需要。我说了算。好吧，我们10分钟就到。我说的“我得去尿尿”这句话，到底哪部分你听不懂？我很生气。我的膀胱已经满了。我现在什么事都做得出来，弄得到处都是，弄脏你这辆宝贝小破车里面。好吧，如果我看到加油站，我会把车停下来的。好吧，希望我能撑到那。我觉得我说过，“好吧，希望我能撑到那。”我觉得我有。哦，天哪，
I'm horrible on a road trip. I can't drink anything because I have to pee like every 30 minutes. Even if I don't drink anything, I have to pee every 30 minutes. Well, this is why I like road tripping with you because you don't sass me at all when I have to pee. You're like, let's find a spot. I know. Let's do it. Well, Jim does stop and while Michael is in the bathroom, Jim gets a phone call from Helene. Guess what? She locked CeCe in her car on the way to the doctor. Yeah. Jim freaks out. He's like, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, I got it. I'll be right there. Yeah. He knocks on the door. He tries to get Michael's attention. Nothing. Nothing coming from the bathroom. It must be the most soundproof door in the world. So Jim just leaves.
我在公路旅行中表现太差劲了。我什么都不能喝，因为我大概每30分钟就要去一次洗手间。就算我什么都不喝，我也得每30分钟去一次洗手间。嗯，这就是为什么我喜欢跟你一起进行公路旅行，因为当我必须去洗手间时，你一点也不会给我脸色看。你会说，我们找个地方吧。我知道。走吧。好吧，吉姆确实停车了，就在迈克尔上洗手间的时候，吉姆接到了海伦的电话。你猜怎么着？她在去医生的路上把西西锁在车里了。对。吉姆吓坏了。他一脸，哦天哪，哦天哪，我懂了。我马上就去。对。他敲门。他试图引起迈克尔的注意。什么都没有。洗手间里一点动静都没有。那绝对是世界上隔音效果最好的门。所以吉姆只好直接走了。
Well, he does tell a man that's getting gas. Listen, there's going to be a guy come out of there, please tell him I had to go. And then of course, the guy just makes no effort and leaves. Yes. He has a shirt on that says Ben. So I'm calling him Ben Gas Station Guy. He was played by Jesse Mackie, a great actor. He's been on better things. This is us, Parks and Recreation. He played the dad and the revival of Saved by the Bell. It's very clear that Jim thinks he works there, maybe, but he doesn't. If you go to five minutes, 40 seconds, I don't know why this made me laugh, but you guys, it made me laugh every time I watched this episode and I rewatched this episode like three times. And every single time when Michael walks out of the bathroom with that
嗯，他确实告诉了一个正在加油的男士。听着，一会儿会有一个家伙从那里面出来，请告诉他我有急事先走了。然后当然了，那个人根本没当回事就走了。是的。他身上穿着一件写着“本”的衬衣。所以我叫他“加油站本”。他由杰西·麦基饰演，是个很棒的演员。他演过《更美好的事》、《我们这一天》、《公园与休憩》，还在《Saved by the Bell》重启版里演过爸爸。很明显，吉姆以为他在那里工作，也许吧，但其实他并没有。如果你看到5分40秒，我不知道为什么这把我逗笑了，但各位，我每次看这一集都会笑，而且我把这一集重温了大概三遍。每一次当迈克尔拿着那个连着钥匙的巨大蓝色塑料棍走出洗手间时……有一次你们去帮我洗牙，我必须去洗手间，我问牙科卫生员，你们有洗手间钥匙吗？她说，有的，等一下，我去给你拿。
giant blue stick that's attached to the key, I one time you guys went to get my teeth cleaned and I had to pee and I asked the dental hygienist, do you guys have a bathroom key? She's like, yeah, one second, let me get it for you. It was attached to the biggest spatula and I was like, what's up with this? And I guess people kept leaving the key in the bathroom. So they just were like, what do we have here? And then in their kitchen, they just tied it to a spatula. I loved that detail when I saw it and made me laugh. We've all carried that giant thing. We've all had to carry like a spatula to the bathroom. We had two fan catches. I guess I'm calling them story logic questions because Don W from Clifton, Virginia said,
那钥匙串在一个最大的铲子上，我当时就想，这怎么回事？我猜是因为人们总是把钥匙留在洗手间里。所以他们大概就在想，我们这儿有什么？然后就在他们的厨房里，直接把它绑在了一个铲子上。我看到那个细节时超级喜欢，把我逗笑了。我们所有人都搬过那个庞然大物。我们所有人都得像拿着铲子一样去洗手间。我们有两个粉丝抓帮。我想我该把它们叫做剧情逻辑问题，因为来自弗吉尼亚州克利夫顿的唐·W说，吉姆把迈克尔一个人留在加油站，但为什么吉姆不告诉纪录片摄制组把消息传达给迈克尔，而是去跟一个路人说话呢？哦天哪，对啊。然后来自俄亥俄州代顿市的杰西卡·M说，我们没有看到纪录片摄制组坐在吉姆车的后座上。所以我们只能假设他们开着另一辆车去了加油站。他们为什么不直接把迈克尔带回办公室呢？在这两种情况下，我都多少能理解。我觉得纪录片摄制组确实不会插手。如果吉姆丢下迈克尔，他们是不被允许介入的。他们本该严格地只管拍摄而不参与，也不去改变正在发生的事情的结果。不过，说实话，我其实很想看到这样一个时刻：迈克尔看着他们说，吉姆去哪儿了？然后他们……就像是，他真的会冲他们发飙吗，说真的，伙计们，拜托。我同意。
Jim leaves Michael at the gas station, but why didn't Jim tell the documentary crew to relay the message to Michael rather than talking to a random person? Oh my gosh, yes. And then Jessica M from Dayton, Ohio says, we don't see the documentary crew in the backseat of Jim's car. So we have to assume they drove a separate car to the gas station. Why didn't they just take Michael back to the office? In both cases, I kind of get it. I think the documentary crew really doesn't get involved. If Jim left Michael, they're not supposed to. They're supposed to literally just watch and not participate and not change the outcome of things that are happening. I would have maybe though, actually loved a moment where Michael looked at them and said,
吉姆把迈克尔丢在加油站，但为什么吉姆不让纪录片摄制组把消息传给迈克尔，而是去和一个路人说话？哦天哪，没错。来自俄亥俄州代顿的杰西卡·M说，我们没看到纪录片摄制组坐在吉姆的车后座上。所以我们只能假设他们是开着另一辆车去的加油站。他们为什么不直接把迈克尔送回办公室？这两种情况我都大概能理解。我觉得纪录片摄制组真的不会介入。如果吉姆把迈克尔丢下，他们是不应该管的。他们字面上的职责就是旁观，不参与，也不改变正在发生的事情的结果。其实我甚至会很希望看到这样一个时刻，迈克尔看着他们然后说，
where'd Jim go? And they're like, maybe he calls them out like seriously guys, come on. I agree. Jim is now going to call Pam and let her know about CC. He's like, don't worry. It's all okay. I have a background catch. I have one too. It's a busted. Is it at five minutes, 56 seconds? Is it you playing Presale in the background of this whole scene? Yes, I move a whole stack of cards over. I'm not trying to hide it at all. Not at all. Jim is going to tell Pam that he left Michael at a gas station on Bennett Street. I went to Google Maps. There is a Bennett Street in Scranton, but I could not find a gas station. Yeah. Pam says, don't worry. She's going to put out an APB and ask Pam Beasley. And then she's like, nothing like Jim is silent. She's like,
吉姆现在要打电话给帕姆，告诉她关于西西的事。他说，别担心。一切都好。我有一个背景抓帮。我也有一个。是个当场抓帮。是不是在5分56秒？是不是你在这个场景的背景里玩纸牌接龙？是的，我把厚厚一叠牌给移过去了。我一点也没想藏着。完全没有。吉姆要告诉帕姆，他在本尼特街的一个加油站把迈克尔落下了。我去查了谷歌地图。斯克兰顿确实有一条本尼特街，但我找不到加油站。对，帕姆说，别担心。她要发个通缉令（APB），然后问帕姆·比斯利。然后她就像是……吉姆一声不吭。她说，你没听到我说话吗？他说，不，我听到了。我觉得这话太刻薄了。帕姆为这句台词准备了一些糖果袋备选台词。你知道她准备了。什么？对，你准备了。就为了这个通缉令？没
did you not hear me? He goes, no, I heard you. I was like, so harsh. Pam had some candy bag alts for this line. You know, she did. What? Yeah, you did. Just for this APB? That's right. Okay. All right. What else did I say? You said, got it. I will pass that information on to someone who cares even more than me. Pam says, here's another one. Got it. Give me the address and I will organize a search party of people that are not me. Okay. And here's another one. Oh, speaking of babies in crisis, what's the address? I'll form a search party. Okay. Which I don't think Pam would have said because. No. You know what? That brings up remnants of the Tittay. The Tittay. The Tittay from the birthing episode. And then the last one was,
错。好吧。好吧。我还说了什么？你说，知道了。我会把这个消息传达给一个比我还要在乎的人。帕姆说，还有另一个。知道了。把地址给我，我会组织一个比我更不在乎的人组成的搜寻队。好吧。还有另一个。哦，说到处于危机中的婴儿，地址是什么？我会组建一个搜寻队。好吧。我觉得帕姆是不会这么说的，因为。不。你知道吗？这勾起了人们对“蒂塔”（Tittay）的回忆。“蒂塔”。来自生孩子那一集的“蒂塔”。然后最后一个是，我相信他足够聪明，能找到办法。其实，你知道吗？你最好还是把地址给我。我喜欢这句台词。说到加油站，在那里工作的员工由尤金·科德雷饰演，他演过各种作品——《良善之地》、《我本疯狂》、《副总统》、《神烦警探》——他就是不让迈克尔用电话。
I'm sure he's smart enough to find a way. Actually, you know what? You better give me the address. I like that line. Speaking of the gas station, the employee who works there, who was played by Eugene Cordero, who's been in everything, the good place, crazy ex-girlfriend, Veep, Brooklyn 99, he will not let Michael use the phone. No. But then Michael will not give up. So he's like, fine, you can make a call. But then Michael doesn't know the number for the office anyway, because he can't use his speed dial. He only has it on speed dial. I mean, how many phone numbers do you know? Because I feel like this is me. I know like my parents phone number. I know obviously like my husband's phone number. Jenna, I don't think I know your phone number. I have
不让用。但迈克尔毫不放弃。所以他说，好吧，你可以打个电话。但迈克尔根本不知道办公室的电话号码，因为他没法用他的快速拨号。他只把号码存了快速拨号。我是说，你知道多少个电话号码？因为我觉得这简直就是我。我大概只知道我父母的电话号码。当然啦，我还知道我老公的电话号码。珍娜，我觉得我不知道你的电话号码。我其实在脑子里记着一个号码，但我不知道那是你的还是我妹妹的。我确实知道。我能想象出来。好吧。但是，是的，我想我大概只知道四个电话号码。是你的吗？不是。那是谁的号码？我不知道。等等，是你的吗？是的。哦天哪，太棒了。好吧，你知道的。
actually number in my head and I don't know if it's yours or my sister's. I do know it. I can see it. Okay. But yeah, I know like four phone numbers, I think. Is yours? No. Whose number is that? I don't know. Wait, is yours? Yes. Oh my gosh, that's great. Well, you know. Hold on, what is your number? I have to know. You were close. I was. No, we're near. You got the area. Oh, I got the area code. I mean, big whoop. What number was I called? Oh, it's my accountant. Hey, I mean, come on, that's close. Oh my God. That is hilarious. That's my accountant's phone number. I mean, listen, listen, I have to call that number a lot. Like when I'm in a bind or I have a question. But technically you're calling an accountant. I'm calling an accountant. Well, when we reached out
等等，你的号码是多少？我得知道。你挺接近的。我是挺接近的。不，一点也不近。你猜对了区号。哦，我猜对了区号。我是说，有啥了不起的。我刚才打的是什么号码？哦，那是我的会计师的电话。嘿，我是说，拜托，这已经很近了。哦天哪。太搞笑了。那是我的会计师的电话号码。我是说，听着，听着，我经常得打那个号码。比如当我陷入困境或者有问题要问的时候。但严格来说你打的是会计师的电话。我打的是会计师的电话。好吧，当我们就这一集联系布伦特时，他想跟我们分享他为这个场景构思的一个笑话，以及他那一刻学到了如何为我们的节目进行编剧。所以我们在拍迈克尔·斯科特被困在加油站的戏，他借加油站员工的电话打给办公室。我们在剧本里写的是，迈克尔意识到他不知道办公室的号码，因为他在手机通讯录里总是直接按“办公室”这个词。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔已经准备好表演这个了。就在我们要开拍之前，我提出了这个额外的笑话。我说，如果迈克尔看着那家伙的手机，看到通讯录里有“办公室”，然后迈克尔按下了“办公室”，接着加油站员工面前柜台上的电话就响了，加油站员工狠狠地瞪了他一眼。我觉得自己提出这个点子简直太聪明了。而史蒂夫说，不，迈克尔没那么蠢。他知道他办公室的号码不在这家伙的手机里。所以喜剧迷们，这里有一个很好的教训。
to Brent about this episode, he wanted to share with us about a joke he pitched for the scene and what he learned about writing for our show in this moment. So we're shooting the scene where Michael Scott is stranded at the gas station and he borrows the gas station attendant's phone to call the office. And we had written in the script that Michael realizes he doesn't know the number to the office because he always just presses the word office in the contacts on his phone. And Steve Carell was prepared to perform that. And right before we were going to shoot it, I pitched this extra joke. I said, what if Michael looks at the guy's phone and he sees contacts and he sees the guy has office in his contacts and Michael presses office and then the phone on
向布伦特谈到这一集时，他想和我们分享他为这个场景构思的一个笑话，以及他在此时学到的关于为我们的剧集进行编剧的心得。当时我们正在拍摄迈克尔·斯科特被困在加油站的戏份，他借加油站员工的电话给办公室打电话。我们在剧本里写的是，迈克尔意识到自己不知道办公室的号码，因为他总是直接按手机通讯录里的“办公室”这个词。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔已经准备好要表演这个了。就在我们要拍摄之前，我提出了这个额外的笑话。我说，如果迈克尔看那个人的手机，看到通讯录，看到那个人通讯录里也有办公室，然后迈克尔按了办公室，接着电话就
the counter in front of the gas station attendant rings and the gas station attendant glares at him. And I felt very clever for pitching this. And Steve said, no, Michael is not that dumb. He knows that the number to his office is not on this guy's phone. So comedy fans, there's a great lesson here. The office is revered in great part because of the tone of realism, what we sometimes call naturalism. And the secret of naturalism is when you must choose between funny and real, air on the side of real. That's the great lesson that I learned from the great actors on the office. Well, Angela, I have two more things to offer about this scene. Okay. I've got a gas station location tidbit. Not a breakdown, a tidbit. It's a tidbit. It's a breakdown slash tidbit. And then
《办公室》之所以备受推崇，很大程度上是因为它的现实主义基调，我们有时称之为自然主义。而自然主义的秘诀在于，当你必须在搞笑和真实之间做出选择时，要倾向于真实。这就是我从《办公室》里的伟大演员身上学到的伟大教训。好吧，安吉拉，关于这个场景，我还有两件事要讲。好的。我有一个加油站外景花絮。不是剖析，是个花絮。是个花絮。这是一个剖析加花絮。然后我还有一个审查标准。你希望先听哪一个？请先讲审查标准。好的。来自科罗拉多州丹佛市的科里·E的粉丝提问。在重温这一集时，我注意到当迈克尔走进加油站时，他肩膀后面有一个“绿草坪护理”（Grasshopper Lawn Care）的标志。那是我的朋友在宾夕法尼亚州的一家草坪护理公司。我问过她这件事，她说你们做了一次道具植入。
I also have a standards and practices. Which one would you like first? Standards and practices, please. All right. Fan question from Corey E and Denver, Colorado. In rewatching this episode, I noticed that when Michael goes into the gas station over his shoulder, there is a grasshopper lawn care sign behind him. That is my friend's Pennsylvania based lawn care company. I asked her about it and she said, you guys did a prop drop. Oh, this is true. Phil Shea got this actual sign from a local company. He had it put up in the background of the scene to give it a kind of local credibility. However, Randy said that originally the sign had the real phone number for the business. It was like 1-800-LONECARE, I think, and it is on the sign. And standards and
哦，这是真的。菲尔·谢伊从当地一家公司弄来了这个真实的标志。他把它挂在场景的背景中，赋予其一种本土的可信度。然而，兰迪说最初这个标志上写着该企业的真实电话号码。大概是1-800-LONECARE之类的，而且标志上确实有。但审查标准（Standards and Practices）对其提出了警告。他们说这不是一个获得授权的电话号码，你们必须在后期制作中将其数码移除。他们总是这么傲慢。我知道。但至少这一次他们不用打那些唇部动作打码的脏话了。我不知道他们是不是气炸了。我不知道他们是不是在想，哦，只是个标志而已。其实，我猜他们的邮件里写的是，请把标志上那个该死的电话号码数码移除。它没有获得授权。正如先前所述。没错。请删掉那个该死的电话号码。这里是你的外景花絮。我们在范奈司的“公民中心加油站暨便利店”（Civic Center Gas Station and Minimart）拍摄的。它现在已经关门了，但它的Yelp评价页面还在。
practices flagged it. They said this is not a cleared phone number and you're going to have to digitally remove it and post production. So much sass from them always. I know. But at least this time they didn't have to type any lip flap curse words. I wonder if they were bombed. I wonder if they're like, oh, just a sign. Actually, I think that their email said, please digitally remove the f***ing phone number from the sign. It is not cleared. As previously stated. Exactly. Please lose the f***ing phone number. Here is your location tidbit. We shot this at Civic Center Gas Station in Minimart. It's in Van Nuys. It is now closed, but their Yelp review page is still up. And it had one four-star review and three one-star reviews. Were they at the bathroom?
上面有一个四星评价和三个一星评价。他们是在说洗手间吗？这里是其中一个一星评价。引述如下。“洗手间能给七分，主要是为了安安静静地享受一段好时光。什么？你在里面干什么呢？我的朋友一直在拼命砸门想引起我的注意，而我什么也听不见。哦，拜托。拜托。这让我的体验变得很平和。不过，收银员又是另一回事了。不仅态度粗鲁，还暗示我的朋友把我丢在那里——我最好的朋友，而且当我需要借用他的电话时，他的快速拨号里居然没有存任何我的号码让我叫车。结果证明我朋友确实把我留下了，好像是因为什么婴儿紧急情况。”是谁写的？那是我们的编剧之一，还是节目的粉丝？不，只是节目的粉丝。太牛了。太牛了，对吧？是的。我真的很喜欢那个小花絮。哦天哪。太棒了。
Here is one of the one-star reviews. Okay. Quote. Bathroom gets seven out of ten, mostly for a quiet, enjoyable time. What? What are you doing in there? My friend was banging on the door to get my attention and I couldn't hear a thing. Oh, come on. Come on. Made my experience peaceful. The cashier is another story, though. Not only was he rude, suggested my friend abandoned me there, my best friend, but when I needed to use his phone, he didn't have any of my numbers on speed dial for me to call a ride. Turns out my friend did leave me something about a baby emergency. Who wrote that? Was it one of our writers or was that a fan of the show? No, it was just a fan of the show. That's brilliant. Brilliant, right? Yes. I really liked that little
好吧，迈克尔有一个单人访谈镜头，他说，你知道吗？这挺好的。我其实要趁这个机会去漫游一下，而且不要摄像机。他把摄像机赶走了，这他以前从不这样做。这个单人访谈原本有一段糖果袋备选台词。哦，请务必讲讲。迈克尔是这么说的。今天可不是搞你那些恶作剧的好日子，吉姆。我昨天倒是很乐意。我肯定会笑掉大牙。但你知道吗？这是因祸得福（blessing in the skies）。因祸得福（blessing in the skies）。因祸得福。我真的很喜欢迈克尔把成语说错的时候。我也喜欢，因为我能感同身受。我也可能会说出“blessing in the skies”这种话。回到办公室里，一个搜寻队正在集结。
tidbit. Oh my gosh. That's awesome. Well, Michael's going to have a talking head where he says, you know what? This is good. I'm actually going to take this opportunity to go walk about and no cameras. He shoots the cameras away, which he never does. There was a candy bag alt for this talking head. Oh, please. This is what Michael says. This was not the day for one of your prankaroonies, Jim. I would have loved this yesterday. I would have laughed my butt off. But you know what? This is a blessing in the skies. I'm going walk about blessing in the skies. A blessing in the skies. I really like it when Michael gets phrases wrong. I do too, because I can relate. I might have said blessing in the skies. Back at the office, a search party
趣闻。哦天哪。太棒了。好吧，迈克尔会有一个单人采访镜头，他说，你知道吗？这挺好的。我其实要趁这个机会去进行一次“漫游”，而且不带摄像机。他把摄像机赶走了，他从不这么做。这个单人采访镜头有一个糖果袋的备用版本。哦，拜托。迈克尔是这么说的。今天可不是开你那些恶作剧玩笑的日子，吉姆。我要是昨天遇到这个肯定会喜欢。我会笑得屁滚尿流。但你知道吗？这是因祸得福（blessing in the skies）。我要去漫游了，因祸得福。因祸得福。我真的很喜欢迈克尔把俗语说错的时候。我也喜欢，因为我能感同身受。我也可能会说出因祸得福这种话。回到办公室，搜救队
is forming. It is going to consist of Holly, Aaron, and Dwight. Yes. Dwight is going to say that he can't drive though, because he's got a car full of Foxmeat. I can't even tell you how many alts they had for that line. For why he can't drive? Like two pages of alts. I'm not even kidding. I don't doubt it. I'm just going to give you three, because there were so many. Okay. Here they were. You drive. I have a car full of Scarecrow heads. You drive. I have a car full of pennies. Stupid bank only lets me convert 10,000 a day. You drive. I have a car full of Christmas ornaments. I'm returning 30 days and I have the receipts. There were two pages of these. I want more. I wish there were more. There were. I just didn't know if I would bore you
正在组建。由霍莉、亚伦和德怀特组成。没错。不过德怀特会说他不能开车，因为他的车里装满了狐狸肉。我都无法形容他们为这句台词准备了多少备选。关于他为什么不能开车？大概有两页纸的备选。我可没开玩笑。我完全相信。我只给你们三个，因为实在太多了。好吧。它们是这样的。你来开。我的车里装满了稻草人头。你来开。我的车里装满了硬币。该死的银行每天只允许我兑换一万。你来开。我的车里装满了圣诞装饰品。我正在退货期内，而且我有收据。这些有整整两页。我还想看更多。我希望还有更多。有的。我只是不知道如果我读一大堆，
guys if I just read a ton of them. They're very funny. My goodness. Well, listen, I think we should take a break. When we come back, we're going to learn all about sticky quips. Oh, yes. And we're going to see who has the best instincts for finding Michael. We're in the kitchen at eight minutes, five seconds. We get a nice shot of Pam's doodle. Randy shared with us that at this time, Henry Sane, our graphics designer, had left our show to direct a feature. We all loved Henry. He was amazing. But for this episode, we added a new member to our art department, Michael Bay Youth. And he would be our graphic artist for this episode. So that is who designed this doodle. Pam is very tickled because she
会不会让你们觉得无聊。它们非常搞笑。天哪。好吧，听着，我想我们该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将全面了解妙语贴。哦，对。我们还要看看谁最有直觉找到迈克尔。在八分钟五秒时，我们在厨房里。我们看到了潘涂鸦的一个精彩镜头。兰迪跟我们分享说，当时我们的平面设计师亨利·塞恩已经离开剧组去导演电影长片了。我们都很喜欢亨利。他太棒了。但对于这一集，我们为美术部门添加了一名新成员，迈克尔·贝·尤思。他将担任我们这一集的平面设计师。所以，这就是设计这个涂鸦的人。潘觉得很高兴，因为她
notices that people have added captions to the bottom of her doodle. Yeah. And they're quite funny. So she's actually going to walk into the bullpen and say, guys, these are fun. This starts a whole caption contest runner for the episode, and everyone really wants to get involved, especially Daryl. Yeah, apparently Daryl writes his own captions for Family Circus, and his daughter cracks up. He's really good at it. I did a little mini deep dive on caption contests. Oh, I knew you would. So first of all, this episode of The Office appears on the Wikipedia page about caption contests and the history of caption contests. Yes. So according to this Wikipedia page, the first printed caption contest seems to have appeared in Life Magazine,
注意到人们在她的涂鸦底部添加了说明文字。是的。而且它们非常搞笑。所以她实际上要走进办公区说，伙计们，这些很有趣。这就引发了这一集的一个贯穿始终的说明文字比赛，每个人都非常想参与进来，尤其是达里尔。对，显然达里尔为《家庭马戏团》写他自己的说明文字，他女儿笑得前仰后合。他真的很擅长这个。我对说明文字比赛做了一点小小的深入研究。哦，我就知道你会的。首先，关于《办公室》这一集的维基百科页面上，就出现了说明文字比赛以及说明文字比赛的历史。是的。所以根据这个维基百科页面，最早印刷的说明文字比赛似乎出现在《生活》杂志上，
which ran from 1883 to 1936. But this was fascinating to me. Okay. They were not called caption contests. They were called picture title contests or picture headline contests. And here's why. Why? The word caption didn't exist. Come on. It didn't. Who invented the word caption? I don't know, but it did not show up in the English language until the first half of the 20th century. Huh. Now you go on Instagram, people post a photo and say caption this. Yeah. You better be careful when you write that sometimes. Well, that is true. And I've got a little fun fact as well. Okay. OfficeTelly.com ran a caption contest after this episode aired. They put up the drawing of the saber printer and people could submit captions. And here were a
该杂志从1883年持续出版到1936年。但这让我觉得很着迷。好吧。它们不叫说明文字比赛。它们被称为图片标题比赛或图片通栏标题比赛。原因如下。为什么？“说明文字”（caption）这个词根本不存在。拜托。真的没有。谁发明了“说明文字”这个词？我不知道，但它直到20世纪前半叶才在英语中出现。哈。现在你去Instagram上，人们发张照片然后说“给这张图配个文”。对。有时候你写这个的时候可得小心点。嗯，确实如此。我也知道一个有趣的冷知识。好吧。OfficeTelly.com在这集播出后举办了一场说明文字比赛。他们贴出了赛博打印机的图画，人们可以提交说明文字。以下是我觉得很有趣的几个。
couple that I thought were fun. Was there a winner? There was. And the winner got a prize package. They got a DVD, The Office Overtime, a Creed Thoughts shirt, and a Dunder Mifflin coffee tumbler. So fun. Right? Let's hear some. Okay. So the contest page is down, but some people had also submitted their captions in the comments, which are still up. Brick wrote, quote, I work so hard so my son can become a scanner. That was one. And then Jordan went with, Hey, look over here. I'm just about as white and square as Gabe. So he really went. He really went for Gabe. In the direction of the episode. Dwight, Holly, and Aaron are searching for Michael. They start with the gas station. They asked the gas station attendant which way
有获胜者吗？有的。获胜者获得了一个奖品包。他们得到了一张DVD：《办公室加班时间》、一件“克里德思想”T恤和一个邓德米夫林咖啡随行杯。太有趣了。对吧？让我们听几个。好吧。所以比赛页面已经撤下了，但有些人也在评论区提交了说明文字，现在还能看到。布里克写道，引述：“我工作这么努力，是为了让我的儿子能成为一台扫描仪。”这是其中一个。然后乔丹写的是：“嘿，看这里。我和盖布一样白、一样方。”所以他真的冲着。他真的冲着盖布去了。顺着这一集的剧情。德怀特、霍莉和亚伦正在寻找迈克尔。他们从加油站开始。他们问加油站服务员迈克尔去了哪边。
Michael went. And as it turns out, it's exactly where Holly would have gone. She had predicted that he might have gone in the direction of the bakery just for the smell. And that's the way he went. Yeah. At nine minutes and 37 seconds, you see this sign for a bakery. The thing that Holly sees that was a fake bakery doesn't exist. We made that sign. And I guess past the bakery, Michael's going to wander into a pet store where he's going to start talking to the animals. This was a real pet store on Victory Boulevard in Burbank, California. It was filled with animals, but we didn't use their animals. We brought in our own animals. They were provided by Bob Dunn's Animal Services. You know, we used them all the time. Our head trainer was Denise Sanders.
结果证明，这正是霍莉会去的地方。她曾预测他可能为了面包店的气味而朝着面包店的方向去了。而他确实就是朝那个方向走的。是的。在九分钟三十七秒时，你看到了这个面包店的招牌。霍莉看到的那个东西是个假面包店，根本不存在。那个招牌是我们制作的。我想过了面包店之后，迈克尔会溜达进一家宠物店，然后他会在那里开始跟动物说话。这是加州伯班克胜利大道上的一家真实的宠物店。里面有很多动物，但我们没有用他们的动物。我们带来了我们自己的动物。它们由鲍勃·邓恩动物服务公司提供。你知道，我们一直都在用他们。我们的首席训练师是丹尼斯·桑德斯。
Randy sent us the photos of the puppies that they cast. It's so cute. I'll put it in stories. We have all the pictures of these little dogs. That's the job I want. I want the job where I look through the puppy pictures and I pick puppies for a day of work. We don't know the names of the tiny golden retrievers, but the Yorkie was played by Amos. Michael talks to a macaw who was named Hook. He talks to a snake. We don't know the snake's name. Sorry, guys. And we used two puppies to play the quote licking puppy. They were very cute. You know, we got a fan question from Natasha C. in Dallas, Texas. When Michael was in the pet store holding the puppy, the puppy licks his nose. Was the puppy trained to do this or was this just perfect timing and improv on Michael's part?
兰迪给我们发了他们挑选的小狗的照片。太可爱了。我会把它发到快拍里。我们有所有这些小狗的照片。那才是我想要的工作。我想要的工作是翻看小狗的照片，然后挑选小狗来工作一天。我们不知道这些小金毛的名字，但约克夏是由阿莫斯扮演的。迈克尔跟一只名叫“胡克”的金刚鹦鹉说话。他跟一条蛇说话。我们不知道这条蛇的名字。对不起啦，各位。我们用了两只小狗来扮演那个所谓的“舔人小狗”。它们非常可爱。你知道，我们收到了来自德克萨斯州达拉斯的娜塔莎·C的粉丝提问。当迈克尔在宠物店里抱着小狗时，小狗舔了他的鼻子。这只小狗是训练成这样的，还是迈克尔完美的时机和即兴发挥？
I'll tell you what, Natasha, all of the little pet store vignettes were scripted. They sound so off the cuff, but everything, the things he says to the snake, the thing he says to the macaw, all scripted, including the part where the puppy was supposed to lick his nose. The puppy licks his nose exactly in the spot it's supposed to. I don't know how they did it. How did they pull that off? I don't know because it's not supposed to lick them at first. It's supposed to lick them in the middle, all scripted. And Steve did such a great job of making that just feel like 100% spontaneous. I know all of it. Back at the office, Pam was like, well, if I knew you guys loved caption contests, I would have drawn something different that you could really have fun with.
我来告诉你，娜塔莎，所有的小宠物店片段都是按剧本拍的。它们听起来像是随性发挥，但所有内容，他跟蛇说的话，他跟金刚鹦鹉说的话，都是按剧本来的，包括小狗舔他鼻子那一段。小狗正好在它该舔的位置舔了他的鼻子。我不知道他们是怎么做到的。他们是怎么办到的？我不知道，因为它一开始不该舔它们的。它应该舔中间，全部都是按剧本来的。史蒂夫把那一段演得太棒了，让人感觉百分之百是自然流露。我全都知道。回到办公室里，潘说，好吧，如果我知道你们这么喜欢说明文字比赛，我就会画点别的让你们真的能玩得开心的东西。
And so she does. She draws two large dogs on an island with two palm trees. But before anybody can give their captions, Gabe kind of shuts it down. Yeah, he's a total fun stopper. He says they can do it if they can agree on some ground rules. Number one, no insulting the company. Number two, no pop culture references. And finally, they have to write their captions on Dunder Mifflin Saber's sticky quips. Yes. And then Gabe has a talking head. He says sticky quips are fun. They're safe. They're handy. I like to use sticky quips as regular post-it notes when I'm in a fun mood. I mean, not every day. There was an alt for this talking head where Gabe simply just said,
然后她真的画了。她在两个棕榈树的小岛上画了两只大狗。但还没等任何人给出说明文字，盖布就把这事儿给叫停了。对，他是个十足的扫兴鬼。他说如果大家能就一些基本规则达成一致，他们就可以玩。第一，不许侮辱公司。第二，不许有流行文化梗。最后，他们必须把说明文字写在邓德米夫林赛博公司的妙语贴上。是的。然后盖布有一个单人访谈。他说妙语贴很有趣。它们很安全。它们很便携。当我心情好的时候，我喜欢把妙语贴当成普通的便签纸来用。我是说，也不是每天都用。这个单人访谈其实有一个备选，盖布在里面只是简单地说，
I don't have a lot of responsibility here. Oh, wow. We had a fan question from Joshua P. in Cincinnati. Did sticky quips already exist out there somewhere? Or did Phil Shea have to find a way to create them? Well, Joshua, they did not exist. Let's give you a visual of a sticky quip. It's basically a post-it note, but it's shaped like an idea bubble. Like an idea bubble. Yeah. And Phil Shea had to design them. And he used Earl Hay Press to manufacture and package them. But I found what I'm calling a Reddit catch. Oh. When I googled sticky quips, I found this catch on Reddit. It's pretty fantastic. Let's hear it. It says, at 15 minutes and 32 seconds in the pilot episode of the office, Jim has a doodle taped to his
我在没有承担很多责任。哦，哇。我们收到了来自辛辛那提的约书亚·P的粉丝提问。妙语贴在现实中原本就存在吗？还是菲尔·谢伊不得不设法创造它们？嗯，约书亚，它们原本是不存在的。让我们给你展示一下妙语贴的视觉效果。它基本上就是一张便签纸，但形状是一个想法气泡。就像一个想法气泡。是的。而且菲尔·谢伊必须设计它们。他找了厄尔·海伊印刷厂来制造和包装它们。但我发现了被我称为“红迪网大发现”的东西。哦。当我谷歌搜索“妙语贴”时，我在红迪网上发现了这个大发现。这太棒了。我们来听听。上面说，在《办公室》试播集的十五分钟三十二秒时，吉姆的电脑显示器上贴着一个涂鸦。
computer monitor. It's while he's eating some jello. Okay. And there are four mini sticky notes with word bubbles drawn on them with captions inside. So someone has captioned this doodle, or four people have captioned this doodle using sort of the original sticky quip. Huh. It was kind of cool. Yeah. Well, we asked Brent about the name sticky quips. And this is what he had to say. He said, that's just one of those two word phrases that comedy writers love. It's got multiple K sounds, plus a T and a P, five plosives in two words. That's comedy power, people. Angela, could you write a good caption for a picture? Because I could not. I just am not that clever. I do enjoy it. I like it. Yes. And they often do it at school. You know, our son is in
那是在他吃果冻的时候。好吧。上面有四个迷你便签，画了对话气泡，里面写着说明文字。所以有人给这个涂鸦配了说明文字，或者说有四个人用某种最初的妙语贴给这个涂鸦配了说明文字。哈。这挺酷的。嗯，我们问过布伦特关于“妙语贴”这个名字的由来。他是这么说的。他说，这只是喜剧编剧们喜欢的那种双词短语。它有多个K音，外加一个T和一个P，两个词里有五个爆破音。这就是喜剧的力量，各位。安吉拉，你能给一张照片写出一个好的说明文字吗？因为我不能。我就是没那么聪明。我确实很享受。我喜欢它。是的。他们在学校里也经常这样做。你知道，我们的儿子在
sixth grade, they do a caption contest and he won one week. Really? Oh my gosh. I'm very impressed by that. I think maybe that is the same thing that would hold me back as an improviser. I just get in my head about it. And I can't, it doesn't flow for me. Oh, I love a good caption contest. Well, you're an improv person. I feel like that makes so much sense. Michael's getting hungry. He's going to stop at a hot dog stand, but he doesn't have any money. So he offers his watch. The hot dog guy says no. Michael's like, well, what do you do with the unsold hot dogs? And the guy says they throw him away at the end of the day. And Michael's like, why don't you throw one into my mouth? Right. I loved the hot dog guy. Yeah, he was fantastic. He was played by Chris Denuzio,
六年级时，他们举行了一场说明文字比赛，他还赢了一周的比赛。真的吗？哦天哪。我对这一点印象深刻。我想这可能就是作为即兴演员会阻碍我的地方。我总是自己想太多。而且我做不到，它对我来说不够顺畅。哦，我很喜欢精彩的说明文字比赛。好吧，你是个即兴表演达人。我觉得这太合情合理了。迈克尔开始饿了。他要在热狗摊停下来，但他身上没有钱。所以他用手表作抵押。热狗摊老板说不行。迈克尔就问，那你们怎么处理卖剩的热狗？那个人说他们会在一天结束时把它们扔掉。迈克尔就说，那你为什么不把一个扔进我嘴里呢？对。我喜欢那个热狗摊老板。对，他棒极了。他由克里斯·德努齐奥饰演，
and he's been on the mentalist new girl law and order, but I stumbled across his bio and listened to this. Quote, after graduating Princeton with a bachelor's degree in history, Chris had a brief stint in the NFL with the Buffalo Bills. What? Then he moved into the investment banking world. And during this time, he also embarked on an acting and writing career. Such like a diverse background. I know. History degree, NFL, investment banking, actor. I feel like you've covered all of it. Here's a little location breakdown for you of the hot dog stand. It is a real place called Larry's Chili Dog. It is on Burbank Boulevard in Burbank, California. It has 4.5 stars on Yelp. It is open from 7 a.m. to 3 p.m. They also serve breakfast.
他演过《超感神探》、《杰茜驾到》、《法律与秩序》，但我无意中刷到了他的个人简历，听听这个。引述：“克里斯从普林斯顿大学历史系获得学士学位后，曾在NFL的布法罗比尔队短暂效力。”什么？然后他进入了投资银行界。在此期间，他还开启了演艺和写作生涯。这背景可真多元。我知道。历史学位、NFL、投资银行、演员。我觉得你已经把各行各业都涉猎了。这里为你简单介绍一下热狗摊的取景地。这是一个真实的地方，名叫“拉里的辣椒热狗”。它位于加州伯班克的伯班克大道上。在Yelp上有4.5星的评价。它从早上7点营业到下午3点。他们也提供早餐。
I looked at the menu and here are some of the hot dogs you can get at Larry's Chili Dog. For breakfast, you can get them from 7 a.m. to 3 p.m. Okay. They also have breakfast burritos. They have breakfast food. But if you want one of their hot dogs for dinner, you're out of luck. But here's what you can have. A chili dog, a corn dog, a veggie dog, just a regular hot dog if you want. But then you can get the New York dog, which comes with grilled onion sauce and spicy mustard. You can also get a Chicago dog, which includes green relish, mustard, tomatoes, onions, celery, salt, dill pickles, and spicy peppers. Gross. Chicago, what are you doing? What's happening? Settle down. Chicago, what's going on? Would you like a Reuben dog? Because that comes
我看了一下菜单，以下是你可以从拉里辣椒热狗买到的一些热狗。早餐你可以从早上7点到下午3点买到。好吧。他们也有早餐卷饼。他们有早餐食品。但如果你想在晚餐时吃他们的热狗，那你可就买不到了。但以下是你可以点到的。辣椒热狗、玉米热狗、素食热狗，如果你想吃的话还有普通热狗。但你还可以点纽约热狗，里面配有烤洋葱酱和辣芥末。你还可以点芝加哥热狗，包括绿色酸豆酱、芥末、西红柿、洋葱、芹菜盐、莳萝酸黄瓜和辣味辣椒。太恶心了。芝加哥，你们在干什么？怎么回事？冷静点。芝加哥，怎么回事？你想来个鲁本热狗吗？因为那个里面有
with sauerkraut, Russian dressing, and melted Swiss cheese and spicy mustard. Oh, my Lord. I mean, it's worse than the Chicago dog. And finally, the Hawaiian dog. Does it have pineapple? It does. Grilled pineapples, onions, and barbecue sauce. I'm intrigued. I might try that one. But here's the kicker. You can also get a puppy patty. If you bring your dog, they'll give you a little beef patty for your dog. And they serve Starbucks coffee. I don't know how, but they do. We'll put this on your tour of Dunder Mifflin Sides, guys, if you come out this way. Yeah. Go get a hot dog at Larry's Chili Dog in Burbank. Michael's going to move on because he sees a huge banner advertising a giant egg roll. This catches his eye. I'll let you know these two spots were
酸菜、俄式沙拉酱、融化的瑞士奶酪和辣芥末。哦，天哪。我是说，这比芝加哥热狗还糟。最后，夏威夷热狗。里面有菠萝吗？有的。烤菠萝、洋葱和烧烤酱。我很感兴趣。我可能会试试那个。但最绝的是。你还可以买到小狗肉饼。如果你带了你的狗来，他们会为你的狗提供一块小牛肉饼。而且他们供应星巴克咖啡。我不知道是怎么做到的，但他们确实做到了。伙计们，如果你来这边的话，我们会把这个加入到你的邓德米夫林巡礼中。对。去伯班克的拉里辣椒热狗吃个热狗吧。迈克尔要继续前进了，因为他看到一个巨大的横幅，上面宣传着一个巨型蛋卷。这吸引了他的眼球。我得告诉你们，这两个地方相距好几英里。
miles away from each other. There was no way that he could actually walk between these two places. Dwight, Erin, and Holly are still searching for Michael. Now we're at a grocery store with them. Dwight comes out and Holly, I guess, is signing up for a new cell phone plan at a little kiosk, like a pop-up tent in the parking lot. Yeah, she's really only doing it because she wants to get the little stress ball. I guess they're giving away free stress balls because she's given a fake name, Fanny Smellmore. And the cell phone lady is like, wow, you must be friends with Orville Tutenbacher. These two are so meant for each other. Yeah. Orville Tutenbacher is Michael's millionaire character who farts popcorn. Dwight and Erin
他根本不可能在这两个地方之间步行穿梭。德怀特、亚伦和霍莉仍在寻找迈克尔。现在我们和他们一起来到了一家杂货店。德怀特出来了，我猜霍莉正在停车场的一个小亭子（就像一个弹出式帐篷）里注册一个新的手机套餐。是的，她这么做其实只是为了拿到那个小压力球。我猜他们在免费赠送压力球，因为她报了一个假名字，叫“范妮·斯梅尔莫尔”（Fanny Smellmore）。手机店的女士就说，哇，你一定是奥尔维尔·图滕巴赫的朋友。这两个人真是天生一对。是的。奥尔维尔·图滕巴赫是迈克尔那个会放爆米花屁的百万富翁角色。德怀特和亚伦
know immediately that Michael's been there. Dwight starts to realize that Holly might just be the key to finding Michael because the two of them think just alike. Yes. So they're going to ask Holly, where did he go next? Where? And Holly sees the same giant egg roll sign and says, are there egg rolls really that big? She's going to wander over there and Dwight and Erin follow her. Before we leave this scene, I do want to give a shout out to our guest star who played the cell phone lady, Amy Height. She has a couple of office connections. She was in Hello Ladies with Stephen Merchant and Rutherford Falls with Ed Helms. Look at that. She was great. I love it. They just miss Michael at the Chinese restaurant. He's just finishing up his food and he's going
立刻就知道迈克尔来过这里。德怀特开始意识到，霍莉可能就是找到迈克尔的关键，因为这两个人的想法简直一模一样。是的。所以他们要问霍莉，他接下来去哪儿了？去哪儿了？而霍莉看到了同一个巨型蛋卷招牌，说，蛋卷真的有那么大吗？她要晃悠过去，德怀特和亚伦紧随其后。在我们离开这个场景之前，我确实想向扮演手机店女士的客串演员艾米·海特致敬。她和《办公室》有几层渊源。她曾和斯蒂芬·莫昌特一起出演过《寻人密探长》，也和埃德·海姆斯一起出演过《罗瑟福德之乡》。你看。她演得太棒了。我太喜欢了。他们在中国餐馆和迈克尔擦肩而过。他刚吃完饭，不得不来个吃霸王餐，
to have to do a dine and dash, or at least he tries to. Yeah, he's too honest for that. I know. And he thinks he should get some points for that honesty. They're like, no, you tried to steal food. And he ate a lot of food. The number three. We had a fan question from Bennett H in Salt Lake City, Utah. Was the Chinese restaurant where Michael tried to dine and dash a real restaurant? And if so, which one? Yes, it was a real restaurant. It still exists. In the show, we called it Mr. Choose Chinese Food Restaurant, but it is actually Kung Pao China Bistro. It is on Ventura Boulevard in Studio City, California, although it is now called Mr. O's. Do you remember back when we did the christening episode? I told you about the woman who has a blog. It's called I am not a
或者至少他尝试这么做了。对，他太诚实了，干不出这事。我知道。而且他觉得自己这种诚实应该得点分。其他人说，不对，你刚才想偷食物。而且他吃了很多食物。三号。我们收到了来自犹他州盐湖城的贝内特·H的粉丝提问。迈克尔试图吃霸王餐的那家中国餐馆是一家真实的餐馆吗？如果是的话，是哪家？是的，它是一家真实的餐馆。它现在还开着。在剧中，我们称它为“周先生中餐厅”，但它实际上叫“宫保中国小酒馆”。它位于加州工作室城的文图拉大道上，尽管现在它改名叫“奥先生”了。还记得当年我们拍摄洗礼那一集的时候吗？我跟你讲过那个写博客的女人。
stalker and she visits locations from TV shows and movies. All right. She went here. Yeah. She got all kinds of pictures of the restaurant. She said the owner was so nice and told her that the reason the office picked this restaurant was because there was a big parking lot next store for all the production vehicles. That sounds right. Yeah, that's why they got picked. Shortly after Michael leaves, Dwight and Aaron and Holly show up. And guess what? They see Michael's photo hanging on the wall. He's holding a little sign that says thief. Go to 16 minutes, you guys, because you are going to see a lot of familiar faces or at least a lot of familiar faces for us, I guess. We had a fan catch from Sessia Z in London, Ontario, Canada. Who noticed that you
她的博客叫“我不是跟踪狂”，她专门参观电视剧和电影的取景地。没错。她去过这里。是的。她拍了各种各样的餐厅照片。她说老板人超级好，告诉她《办公室》之所以选中这家餐厅，是因为隔壁有一个很大的停车场，可以停所有的剧组车辆。听起来很对。对，这就是他们被选中的原因。迈克尔离开后不久，德怀特、亚伦和霍莉就出现了。你猜怎么着？他们看到迈克尔的照片挂在墙上。他手里拿着一个小牌子，上面写着“小偷”。大家快看十六分钟处，因为你们会看到很多熟悉的面孔，或者至少对我们来说很多面孔都很熟悉，我想是的。我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省伦敦市的塞西亚·Z的粉丝发现。她注意到你
can see Creed's picture on the wall? But if you look to the picture on the left, it looks like there is another picture of Creed with a black wig on and he's smiling. I found this hilarious. Then we had a fan question from Amy D in Kirkland, Washington. Who were the people in the thief pictures? Jessica N from Rochester, New York wants to know if any of them are crew members. Yes, you guys. I spotted Kelly Cantley. She's in the top row, third one over. I spotted Laverne, our makeup artist. She was next to Creed. That's who I noticed. I had a hard time seeing the pictures clearly. It's so quickly. I tried to even take a picture of it and zoom in, but then it got blurry. I don't know. Did you notice anyone else? I thought I saw Brian Whittle,
可以看到克里德的照片挂在墙上。但如果你看左边的照片，好像还有另一张克里德戴着黑色假发、正在微笑的照片。我觉得这太搞笑了。然后我们收到了来自华盛顿州柯克兰的艾米·D的粉丝提问。小偷照片里的人都是谁？来自纽约州罗切斯特的杰西卡·N想知道其中是否有人是剧组工作人员。是的，伙计们。我认出了凯莉·坎特利。她在第一排，从左往右数第三个。我还认出了拉弗恩，我们的化妆师。她就在克里德旁边。那就是我认出的人。我很难看清照片。因为过得太快了。我甚至试图拍张照片然后放大，但后来变得很模糊。不知道。你们有注意到其他人吗？我觉得我看到了布兰农·维特尔，
but again, it went by so quickly, but Laverne gets a nice big featured shot. She does, yes. I really want to give a shout out to Ben Wang, who played the Chinese restaurant waiter. He has been in Legion, fresh off the boat, law and order and law and order SVU. You know, I love a law and order alum. Ben was really awesome. Back at the office, nobody is using Gabe's stick equips. They're not doing the caption contest that he wanted because guess what they are doing? They're instant messaging each other. Phyllis stopped being able to minimize her screen or make it go to sleep was the funniest thing. And this is when we noticed that people were using stick equips. Angela, they were using them to
但同样地，画面一闪而过，不过拉弗恩有一个很好的特写镜头。确实，是的。我真的很想向扮演中国餐馆服务员的王班（Ben Wang）致敬。他曾出演过《大群》、《菜鸟新移民》、《法律与秩序》和《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》。你知道的，我很喜欢《法律与秩序》的校友。王班真的很棒。回到办公室里，根本没有人使用盖布的妙语贴。他们没有按照他希望的那样进行说明文字比赛，因为你猜他们在干什么？他们在互相发即时消息。菲利斯无法将她的屏幕最小化或让它进入睡眠状态，这简直太搞笑了。这就是我们注意到人们在用妙语贴的时候。安吉拉，他们用妙语贴
put notes on Gabe's back in a very juvenile manner. And we got a fan question from Mikayla G in State College, Pennsylvania, who said, when you see the stick equips on Gabe's back during the caption contest, why is douche spelled D-O-O-S-H? Could it have been an issue with standards and practices? Oh my gosh. Please tell me you have an email about this, please. Here's what Randy said. I was shocked. He said, we did not get any standards and practices notes over the captions or about the word douche. He says, I can't remember why the spelling was changed, but it must have been a choice made on the day. So believe it or not, standards and practices had nothing to say about this. And Randy shared with us the graphic design they
以一种非常幼稚的方式贴在盖布的背上。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州州立大学的米凯拉·G的粉丝提问，她说，当你在说明文字比赛期间看到盖布背上的妙语贴时，为什么“douche”（混蛋）这个词拼成了D-O-O-S-H？这会不会是审查标准和规范的问题？天哪。请告诉我你有一封关于这个的邮件，拜启。兰迪是这么说的。我很震惊。他说，我们没有收到任何关于说明文字或“douche”这个词的审查标准和规范意见。他说，我不记得为什么要更改拼写，但这肯定是在拍摄当天做出的决定。所以信不信由你，审查标准和规范对这个没有任何意见。兰迪还跟我们分享了他们
put on all of our computers to look like that we had been IM-ing. And I'm going to put those in stories. Oh yeah, because they have all the captions. They have tons of captions that different members in the office came up with. Gabe starts reading all the captions from the IM chat. And basically, they're all either at the expense of Saber or Gabe himself. Yeah, they're not very nice. Completely against the rules. They're really awful. Why is everybody so mean? So mean to Gabe. I didn't get it. The winning caption is, quote, is that a palm tree or did Gabe get skinnier? Either way, let's pee on it. No one knows who wrote it, you know, because their screens have been shut down. Yeah. Gabe won't say. Well, we know. Angel's going to have a talking head that says,
放在我们所有电脑上的平面设计，看起来就像我们在发即时消息一样。我会把那些发到快拍里。哦，对，因为上面有所有的说明文字。上面有办公室里不同成员想出的海量说明文字。盖布开始朗读即时消息聊天中的所有说明文字。基本上，它们全都是在拿赛博公司或盖布本人开涮。是的，它们不太友好。完全违反了规则。它们真的很糟糕。为什么每个人都这么刻薄？对盖布太刻薄了。我搞不懂。获胜的说明文字是，引述：“那是棕榈树还是盖布变瘦了？不管怎样，在上面尿个尿吧。”没人知道是谁写的，你知道的，因为他们的屏幕已经被关掉了。是的。盖布不说。好吧，我们知道。安吉拉将有一个单人访谈，说道，
please, it was easy once I decided I wanted the dog to piss on Gabe. Very crass of Angela Martin, I think to say the word piss, don't you? Yeah, now that you mention it. Well, I had to know where their candy bag alts for this talking head. And yes, there were. There were a lot. I'm going to share two of them. All right. Angela, please, I'm quite humorous. These people would know that if any of them made my Christmas card list. Oh, Angela does a funny Christmas card, but doesn't send it to anyone in the office. And then the next one is, please, I know for a fact, Gabe has had far worse things written about him on the walls of our bathroom, and many other bathrooms around Scranton. Oh, so there's there's something in the women's room
拜托，只要我决定让狗在盖布身上撒尿，这简直易如反掌。安吉拉·马丁说出“撒尿”这个词，我觉得这太粗俗了，你不觉得吗？对，经你这么一说。好吧，我必须知道这个单人访谈有没有糖果袋（指骂人的脏话）的备选。是的，确实有。有很多。我要分享其中两个。好吧。安吉拉，拜托，我很有幽默感。如果这些人把我列入他们的圣诞贺卡名单，他们就会知道了。哦，安吉拉会做一张有趣的圣诞贺卡，但不会寄给办公室里的任何人。然后下一个是，请听着，我很清楚，盖布在我们的卫生间墙壁上以及斯克兰顿周围的许多其他卫生间里，曾被写过更惨的东西。哦，所以斯克兰顿
at Dunder Mifflin about Gabe. Well, Michael is still lost. He's wandering around, but he's going to try to escape the camera crew. He's going to run down an alley. Yeah. This scene was shot in downtown Los Angeles. That's where we are now on location, but we don't know where he's going. We don't. But guess who has an idea, even though she doesn't realize it. It's Holly. Yeah. She's going to say maybe we should go up somewhere high and we might be able to see Michael wandering around down below. Dwight thinks that's a ridiculous idea. And Holly just wanders off on her own. She's going to do it herself. Yeah. Dwight is going to go to a bowling alley. Erin is going to follow Holly. Is Erin going to finally come around? I mean, she started off this
邓德米夫林的女子洗手间里有关于盖布的内容。好吧，迈克尔依然迷路了。他在四处闲逛，但他试图摆脱摄像团队。他跑进了一条小巷。是的。这一幕是在洛杉矶市中心拍摄的。我们现在就在那里的外景地，但我们不知道他要去哪里。我们确实不知道。但你猜谁有个主意，尽管她自己并没有意识到。是霍莉。是的。她说也许我们应该去某个高处，也许就能看到迈克尔在下面四处闲逛。德怀特觉得这简直是个荒谬的主意。而霍莉独自一人溜达开了。她打算自己去。是的。德怀特要去保龄球馆。亚伦跟着霍莉。亚伦最终会转变态度吗？我是说，她这一集一开始对霍莉进行了非常刻薄的单人访谈，但我认为她开始理解了。
episode with such a snarky talking head about Holly, but I think she's starting to get it. Well, I'm sorry. If you do not warm up to them as a couple after you see this next scene, I don't know what's wrong with you. Even Randy in his email to us, he was writing out all his facts about this episode and he said, I have to pause here and tell you that I sobbed when I saw Michael and Holly reunited on this roof. It's so emotional. It's such a sweet scene. I do want to point out that Holly apparently had to climb 15 flights of stairs. I know. What? You know, we had a fan catch from Yamina in France. Quote, we clearly see Holly walking in high heels all throughout this episode. But when she's walking up the stairs and finally sees Michael, her shoes are different. The heels
好吧，对不起。如果你看了接下来的这一幕，对他们作为情侣还不动心的话，我真不知道你脑子哪里出问题了。连兰迪在给我们的邮件中，当他写下关于这一集的所有事实时，他说，我必须在这里暂停一下，告诉大家，当我在这个屋顶看到迈克尔和霍莉重聚时，我哭得泣不成声。太感人了。这真的是一个很甜的场景。我确实想指出，霍莉显然不得不爬了十五层楼梯。我知道。什么？你知道的，我们收到了来自法国的雅米娜的粉丝发现。引述：“我们清楚地看到霍莉在这一集的整个过程中都穿着高跟鞋走路。但当她走上楼梯并最终看到迈克尔时，她的鞋子变了。当他们在20分钟38秒接吻时，鞋跟
are not as high when they're kissing at 20 minutes and 38 seconds. Why was this? I do not know why. What a fantastic catch. But it is true. If you look at 19 minutes and 24 seconds as Holly is walking away from Dwight, she has high heels on. But then when she's in the stairwell and on the roof at 19 minutes and 34 seconds, she's in some little kitten heels. I think it's a safety thing. I think they didn't want her wearing high heels on the top of a building. Or on those stairs, which looks a little precarious. As she's walking up the stairs, she's actually only walking on her toes because I think the stairs had little slats and I think her heel would have gotten stuck. Oh, there it is. I think you're right. It was a safety issue. We mom
没有那么高了。”这是为什么呢？我不知道为什么。多棒的一个发现啊。但确实如此。如果你看一下19分24秒，当霍莉从德怀特身边走开时，她穿着高跟鞋。但当她在19分34秒处于楼梯间和屋顶时，她穿着一些小猫跟鞋。我觉得这是出于安全考虑。我想他们不想让她穿着高跟鞋站在大楼顶上。或者在那看起来有点危险的楼梯上。当她走上楼梯时，她实际上只用脚尖走路，因为我觉得楼梯有小缝隙，我猜她的鞋跟会卡住。哦，就是这样。我想你是对的。这是一个安全问题。我们妈妈
detective it. We really did. Mom detectives of it. How do you say that? Detective did it? We mom detective did it. We did it. We did it. We did it. The location for this romantic reunion was the rooftop and stairwell of the May Fair Hotel in downtown Los Angeles. If you're visiting, it's on Seventh Street. Brent shared with us about this scene. I thought this was such a cool thing that he pointed out. He talks about the tone of all the scenes and how this one is different from any other in the whole episode. Let's hear it. I remember the energy of the actors in the A story was very fun. It was Rainn Wilson, Ellie Kemper, Amy Ryan, and Steve Carell. We're zipping around the city and shooting these fun little set pieces in a parking lot, in a restaurant. The energy is
侦探附体了。我们真的是。妈妈侦探附体。这句话怎么说？侦探上身了？我们妈妈侦探上身了。我们做到了。我们做到了。这场浪漫重聚的取景地是洛杉矶市中心美景酒店的屋顶和楼梯间。如果你来参观，它在第七街。布伦特跟我们分享了这个场景。我觉得他指出的这一点太酷了。他谈到了所有场景的基调，以及这一幕与整集中任何其他场景的不同之处。我们来听听。我记得A故事中演员们的能量非常有趣。那是雷恩·威尔逊、艾莉·肯珀、艾米·瑞安和史蒂夫·凯瑞尔。我们在城市里穿梭，在停车场、餐厅里拍摄这些有趣的场景片断。这种能量非常
very elevated until the scene on the rooftop. Normally, when you're shooting on location, there's a fair amount of shouting among the crew. They're trying to convey info outdoors, but on this set, on that scene, the crew was whispering. I remember I walked on to set like a doofus yapping about something, and I immediately went silent. I looked around. Why is everyone being so quiet? I saw Amy and Steve in the distance. The crew had given them a lot of space out of respect for what they were doing. They were great actors enacting real love between these two characters. The energy was sacred. It's such a great scene. They have this moment where she just finally melts and they kiss, Erin sees it, she's smiling, and you just know
高涨，直到屋顶的场景。通常情况下，你在外景拍摄时，剧组成员之间会有相当多的喊叫。他们试图在户外传达信息，但在片场，在那场戏中，剧组成员都在窃窃私语。我记得我像个傻瓜一样大声谈论着什么走上片场，然后我立刻就安静了下来。我环顾四周。为什么每个人都这么安静？我看到远处的艾米和史蒂夫。剧组为了尊重他们的表演，给他们留出了很大的空间。他们是伟大的演员，在演绎这两个角色之间真实的爱。这种能量是神圣的。这是一个多么棒的场景。他们有这样一个时刻，她终于卸下防备，他们亲吻了，亚伦看到了，她笑着，你就是知道
finally, finally these two are back together. Also, just as a fan of the show, I was a total audience member when I rewatched this, and I was so emotional for Michael that he finally met his someone. Oh, so awesome. We had a fan question, though. Oh, well, this doesn't sound good. What? From Jade B in Nova Scotia, Canada, who said, How could Michael get lost in the small town that he's from? Why would he need to go to the top of a building to figure out where he is? This never made sense to me. And Mariah L from Colorado Springs agrees. Mariah added, In the client, Michael made fun of Jan for not knowing her way around Scranton and said he spent his whole life here. I realized that the writers wanted to find a way to get Holly to realize
终于，终于这两个人重新走到一起了。另外，作为一个剧迷，我重看这一集时完全代入了观众的心态，为迈克尔终于遇到了他的真命天女而感到无比激动。哦，太棒了。不过，我们收到了一个粉丝提问。哦，听起来不太妙。什么？来自加拿大新斯科舍省的杰德·B说：“迈克尔怎么会在他生长的这个小镇上迷路呢？他为什么需要爬到大楼顶上去弄清楚自己在哪里？这对我来说根本说不通。”来自科罗拉多斯普林斯的玛丽亚·L也表示赞同。玛丽亚补充说：“在《客户》那一集里，迈克尔曾取笑简不熟悉斯克兰顿的路，并说他一生都在这里度过。我意识到编剧们是想找到一种方法让霍莉意识到
that Michael really is her soup snake. So maybe the story makes sense if you think that Michael is so depressed and out of sorts that he really could get lost in his own hometown. I have to say, why are you making that face? She's making that face like, you know, like when your mom is maybe talking about someone, but your mom doesn't normally gossip, but maybe she's saying something gossipy and she makes a face like bless his heart. I don't think they're wrong. You don't think they're wrong. I think it's a little bit of a stretch. And by the end, I don't care. By the time they're kissing, I don't care. But I will admit, I thought about it. I thought, how is he so lost in his own city? You know, what's interesting is when I watched it,
迈克尔真的是她的‘汤蛇’（灵魂伴侣）。所以如果你认为迈克尔是如此沮丧和不知所措，以至于他真的会在自己的家乡迷路，那么这个故事也许就说得通了。”我不得不说，你为什么要做那个表情？她做那个表情的样子，就好像，你知道的，就像你妈妈可能在谈论某个人，但你妈妈平时不怎么八卦，不过也许她在说一些八卦的事情，然后她露出一个类似“愿上帝保佑他”的表情。我觉得她们没说错。你觉得她们没错。我觉得这有点牵强。而且到了最后，我根本不在乎。等到他们亲吻的时候，我什么都不在乎了。但我承认，我确实想过这个问题。我想，他怎么会在自己的城市里迷路成这样？你知道，有趣的是，当我观看这一集时，
I didn't think about that at all. Really? Yeah. I watched it and I just thought, this is someone who is having a little bit of a life crisis, right? He thinks he's at a big crossroad with Holly and things are finally going to happen. And when she keeps pushing him away, he just really is searching for it all to make sense. And to me, it just worked. It's like he comes out, he could have found his way back to the office, but I think he wants to go on this walkabout. I think it's intentional. You disagree. I just think like there's got to be some sort of, I mean, if you were lost, wouldn't you go up to a person and ask how far am I from this landmark that we all know? Well, here's what I'm saying. I don't think Michael was physically lost. I think
我根本没想过这个问题。真的吗？是的。我看着它，只是觉得，这是一个正在经历一点点人生危机的人，对吧？他认为他正处于与霍莉的重大十字路口，事情终于要发生了。当她不断把他推开时，他真的只是在寻找这一切能讲得通的意义。对我来说，这完全说得通。就像他走出来一样，他本可以找到回办公室的路，但我认为他是故意去进行这次漫步的。我认为这是故意的。你不同意。我只是觉得，肯定得有某种，我是说，如果你迷路了，难道你不会去找个人问问，离我们大家都知道的这个地标有多远吗？好吧，我要说的是。我不认为迈克尔身体上迷路了。我认为
he was emotionally lost. Oh, look what I did there. I guess. I don't know. Jade, Mariah, I see you, I hear you, but doesn't the kiss just make you not care? Oh, the minute she sees him. I mean, she sobs. She's crying. The minute you see her know. Amy Ryan, my gosh, and Steve Carell. Very good. Very good. This episode ends with a tag. We're back at Dundra Mifflin, and Gabe is reading all of the captions. Guess what? We're going to end this episode with standards and practices, Angela. I bet. Because at 21 minutes and six seconds, Gabe says, bullshit. And here was the note. Please tell me it says lip flap. As previously mentioned, please bleep the underlined completely with no beginning or end consonant sounds and blur
他在情感上迷路了。哦，看我刚才说的。好吧，我想是吧。我不知道。杰德，玛丽亚，我看到你们了，我也听到你们的声音了，但是这个吻难道没有让你们觉得这些都不重要了吗？哦，她一看到他。我是说，她痛哭流涕。她哭了。只要你看到她明白了。艾米·瑞安，天哪，还有史蒂夫·凯瑞尔。太棒了。太棒了。这一集的结尾有一个彩蛋。我们回到了邓德米夫林，盖布正在朗读所有的说明文字。你猜怎么着？安吉拉，我们要以审查标准和规范来结束这一集。我敢打赌。因为在21分6秒时，盖布说了一句“胡说八道”（bullshit）。以下是修改意见。请告诉我上面写的是口型。如前所述，当盖布说“bullshit”且“shit”带有下划线时，请把带下划线的部分完全消音，不要带有任何开头或结尾的辅音发音，并模糊
the visible lip flap when Gabe says bullshit and shit is underlined. So we're allowed to see and hear bull, but we have to bleep the underlined, which was the rest of it. Nothing makes me happier than these standards and practices emails. I could almost just put them in a book as like a coffee table book. Oh, that's a good idea. Well, listen, thank you so much for joining us on the search. A big thank you to Brent Forrester and Randy Cordray. That's right. And you guys, Brent has some wonderful comedy writing classes. You can find them at BrentForrester.com. Thanks so much for listening, and we'll see you next week with some major PDA major. Oh my gosh. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
可见的口型。所以我们可以看到和听到“bull”，但我们必须把带下划线的部分消音，也就是剩下的部分。没有什么比这些审查标准和规范的邮件更让我开心的了。我几乎可以把它们装订成一本书，当成咖啡桌读物。哦，这是个好主意。好吧，听着，非常感谢你们加入我们的搜寻之旅。非常感谢布伦特·福斯特和兰迪·科德雷。没错。伙计们，布伦特有一些精彩的喜剧写作课。你们可以在BrentForrester.com上找到它们。非常感谢大家的收听，我们下周将带着关于大范围PDA的大新闻与大家见面，大范围的。哦天哪。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Ear Wolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Ear Wolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。